unser Finanzminister Christian Lindner
hat ja geheiratet dieses Jahr und wenn
man es nicht besser wüsste könnte man
meinen er hätte ihr hier das Jawort
gegeben so oft und so liebevoll wir über
sie gesprochen hat die Schuldenbremse
Schuldenbremse Schuldenbremse
Schuldenbremse Schuldenbremse es wird zu
der Eindruck erweckt die Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes sei mein persönlicher
Spleen ist aber gar nicht ins Bean von
ihm sagte sondern er muss sie einhalten
Grundgesetz ja und jetzt kommt er tue
das vor allem für die jüngere Generation
jede Milliarde die wir an Schulden
aufnehmen zahlen Sie und zahlen die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer mit Zins
und Tilgungen zurück und ich und die
Kinder und Enkelgeneration und da wird
spannend denn genau die Kinder und
Enkelgeneration die will das offenbar
gar nicht wir sagen es auch als junge
Generation
von der wir immer hören dass unter
anderem unser Finanzminister durch die
Lande zieht und behauptet im Namen der
jungen Generation dürfe keine weiteren
Schulden aufnehmen auch das wollen wir
an der Stelle ganz nachdrücklich vom
Tisch räumen was auch immer Herr
Christian Lindner gerade macht ganz
sicher nicht im Namen der Jugend also
wer hat Recht ist die Schuldenbremse und
das Festhalten an ihr gerecht vor allem
für jüngere oder setzt Lindner ganz im
Gegenteil dadurch die Zukunft der
jüngeren auf Spiel ja dieser Frage
wollen wir heute nachgehen schauen dazu
was genau ist denn die Schuldenbremse
eigentlich noch mal also ihr sollt auch
ein bisschen Hintergrund kriegen damit
er am Ende selbst zu einer fundierten
Antwort kommt geht ja schließlich um
eure Kohle bzw die eure Kinder deswegen
schreibt uns am Ende in die Kommentare
was ihr denkt ja und auf dem Weg zu
unserer Antwort kann ich schon mal
Versprechen gibt es die ein oder andere
interessante Wendung und am Ende daher
ein ziemlich überraschendes Fazit
also Schuldenbremse noch mal ganz kurz
das ist eine Regel die im Kern
vereinfacht besagt dass der Staat nicht
mehr ausgeben darf als er einnimmt ja
damit er nicht Jahr für Jahr mehr
Schulden anhäuft bis er irgendwann
pleite geht die Idee dahinter dass die
Regierung nicht Kohle raushaut als gab
es kein Morgen und jeder
Bevölkerungsgruppe teure Geschenke macht
um wiedergewählt zu werden und diese
Regel steht tatsächlich sogar im
Grundgesetz heißt die kann nicht einfach
von der Regierung kassiert werden dafür
braucht man schon eine 2/3 Mehrheit im
Bundestag also auch Stimmen der
Opposition aber es gibt sozusagen drei
aber drei Ausnahmen Ausnahme 1 ein
bisschen Schulden aufnehmen darf der
Staat jedes Jahr
0,35% vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt warum
0,35 wurscht ist ein komplizierte Formel
merken müsst ihr euch nur das sind
zurzeit so circa 12 Milliarden pro Jahr
es ist für ein Land wie Deutschland das
schon vor der corona-krise weit mehr als
300 Milliarden pro Jahr ausgegeben hat
natürlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel 12
Milliarden zweite Ausnahme aufgepasst
jetzt kommt ein Wort mit dem man
ziemlich angeben kann bei dem Thema
kennt nämlich kaum einer die
konjunkturkomponente die besagt dass man
in Zeiten wusste Wirtschaft also der
Konjunktur nicht gut geht dass man da
noch mal mehr Schulden aufnehmen darf
als diese 0,35 %. 2020 waren das z.B
noch mal so eine Größenordnung 50
Milliarden also schon ganz schöner
Batzen und dann dritte Ausnahme die
weitreichendste die Aussetzung der
Schuldenbremse steht auch im Grundgesetz
und besagt dass man die Schulden Regel
ja sozusagen
ignorieren kann wenn folgendes Eintritt
Naturkatastrophen oder außergewöhnliche
Notsituationen die sich der Kontrolle
des Staates entziehen und genau so eine
Notlage wurde festgestellt in den
letzten drei Jahren 2020 21 22 wegen
Corona der Plan war nächstes Jahr 23
soll die Schuldenbremse dann wieder
greifen bloß ihr wisst nach Corona kam
der Krieg samt all seiner Folgen und da
sagen jetzt viele Richtung
Finanzminister wenn Sie
trotz weil der Bevölkerung in die Armut
getrieben werden dann ist das einfach
nur verantwortungslos verantwortungslos
sagt sie wert er Grab mit Verantwortung
argumentiert mit Verantwortung gegenüber
der jüngeren Generation gucken uns das
also mal genauer an ja wie gesagt geht
ja um euer Geld und machen wir das der
Einfachheit halber mal ich
kneipensprache ja Lindner sagt sinngemäß
jetzt fröhlich und ungehemmt weiter Bier
bestellen und alles anschreiben lassen
sozusagen auf den großen Deckel das sei
ungerecht weil den müssten am Ende eben
andere bezahlen die nachfolgenden
Generationen dann wenn er und seine Crew
allerdings schon raus ist sozusagen aus
der Kneipe das ironische Lindner kann
dabei ein Argument einführen das
kürzlich noch webenden großen Triumph
beschert hat in ihr Fridays for future
nämlich als das Bundesverfassungsgericht
im Staat vorgeschrieben hat du Start
muss jetzt mehr fürs Klima tun mehr CO2
sparen du darfst das nicht in die
Zukunft schieben also kommende
Generationen dazu nötigen du musst das
jetzt selber machen sonst ungerecht auch
dafür gibt es den hübschen Fachbegriff
auch wunderbar fürs Klugscheißer Bingo
geeignet
intertemporale freiheitssicherung heißt
die Politik muss immer auch an die
nächste Generation denken auch die im
Blick haben bei ihren Entscheidungen und
darf nicht dehnen Lasten aufbürden weil
sie jetzt selbst gerade keine Lust drauf
hat diese Lasten zur Schultern ja und da
kommen wir jetzt zurück zum Thema Geld
bzw Schuldenbremse hier ist das Argument
dasselbe wenn der Schuldenberg immer
weiter steigt die Zinsen dafür immer
erdrückender werden bleibt für kommende
Generationen eben immer weniger Geld
übrig über das sie frei verfügen können
über dass Sie frei entscheiden können
das ist im Kern des Lindner Argument ja
Schutz der kommenden Generation nur das
von denen eben viele gar nicht beschützt
werden wollen jedenfalls nicht so ich
kenne wirklich kaum junge Leute die an
dieser Schuldenbremse festhalten wollen
auch deutschlandweit wenn man die Gesam
Bevölkerung befragt haben wir gemacht
genau gesagt die Forschungsgruppe war in
hat das gemacht die Gesamtbevölkerung
befragt und da sieht man tatsächlich je
jünger die Leute desto mehr sind sie für
neue zusätzliche Schulden warum viele
das so sehen erklärt sie hier Jessica
Rosenthal Chefin der Jusos also der
Jugendorganisation der SPD für die sie
seit ungefähr einem Jahr auch im
Bundestag sitzt und sie sagt wenn wir
jetzt die Schuldenbremse einhalten dann
müssen wir quasi alles Geld was uns zur
Verfügung steht für die akute
Krisenbewältigung ausgeben ja und dann
bleibe nix mehr für andere wichtige
Projekte die sich die Ampel vorgenommen
hat und das macht mich ehrlicherweise
schon auch wütend weil man immer wieder
gesagt hat ja den Umbau der Industrie
zum Beispiel machen wir jetzt nicht ist
gerade die oder die Krise die
Unabhängigkeit von den fossilen
Energieträgern können wir jetzt nichts
machen ja das erklärt dann eben auch
warum für viele jüngere die Angst vor
dem Schuldenberg nicht so entscheidend
ist sondern eher die Angst vor den
Konsequenzen wenn jetzt zu wenig
ausgegeben wird
für alle mit Blick aufs Klima das ist
also so grob die Debatte Pro und Contra
wie seht ihr es bevor ihr es aufschreibt
hält sich Christian Lindner überhaupt an
das Prinzip dass ich da gerade
beschrieben habe ist er sozusagen der
Robin Hood der jüngeren vermeidet er
Schulden für Sie nö tut er ganz objektiv
gesehen nicht ja er nimmt die ganze Zeit
neue Schulden auf die kommende
Generation irgendwann zahlen müssen
einziger Unterschied jetzt kommt's er
schreibt diese neuen Schulden um in
unserer kneipensprache zu bleiben nicht
auf seinen eigenen hauptdeckel seinen
Haushalt für den die Schuldenbremse gilt
sondern er schreibt sie auf andere Decke
für die und das ist der Clou die
Schuldenbremse nicht gilt ja noch mal
weit so zentral ist richtig gehört die
Schuldenbremse die gilt nur für seinen
normalen Haushalt oder wie er ihn
inzwischen fast nur noch nennt den
Kernhaushalt ja bloß neben diesem
Kernhaushalt gibt es noch eine Menge
anderer Deckel ja bekannteste kennt ihr
alle hatten besonders schönen Abend der
Deckel Sondervermögen Bundeswehr mit dem
kleinen Schönheitsfehler das ist kein
Vermögen im eigentlichen Sinne ist also
so das was wir darunter verstehen würden
sondern in Wahrheit besteht dieses
Vermögen aus ganz genau neuen Schulden
wie viel ganz normal richtig 100
Milliarden interessant jetzt wie sollen
die denn zurückgezahlt werden da müsste
man ja wenn man so verantwortungsbewusst
ist gegenüber der jüngeren Generation in
ganz konkreten ehrgeizigen
Rückzahlungsplan haben also schauen wir
mal rein was steht denn da so im kleinen
gedruckten
nach vollständiger in Anspruchnahme
spätestens ab 1 Januar 31 sind die
Kredite innerhalb eines angemessenen
Zeitraums eines angemessenen Zeitraums
zurückzuführen ja gut ist jetzt nicht so
konkret ja ich frage mich was mein
Kneipen wird oder meine Bank sagen würde
wenn ich denen sage ihr kriegt euer Geld
ja in einem an passenden Zeitraum ab in
neun Jahren ja und geht weiter so
nächster Deckel der Energie- und
klimafordeckel EFK der ist spannend weil
er auch noch mal 60 Milliarden an
Krediten erlaubt die eigentlich mal
bewilligt wurden zur corona-bewältigung
noch von der letzten Regierung 2021 und
genau darin liegt jetzt auch der Charme
für Lindner und die Ampel weil diese
Kredite belasten auch nicht seinen
Kernhaushalt weil sie eben schon auf dem
Deckel von 2021 stehen und im Prinzip
soll jetzt genau dasselbe gelten für den
sogenannten nämlich die bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro die die Ampel
bereitstellen will unter anderem für die
gaspreisbremse diese Riesensumme wird
nicht im Kernhaushalt verbucht sondern
dafür wird jetzt auch wieder ein anderer
Deckel gefunden der sogenannte
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds kurz WSF
selbes Prinzip den gab es auch schon und
den fühlt man jetzt sozusagen wieder auf
weil dieses Jahr die Daten Bremse ja
noch ausgesetzt ist heißt auch von
diesem 200 Milliarden doppelwumms wird
Lindners Kernhaushalt nicht belastet
also zusammengefasst im Endeffekt heißt
das Deutschland gibt nächstes Jahr das
x-fache von dem aus was die
Schuldenbremse eigentlich zulässt hält
aber rein formal zumindest stand jetzt
trotzdem die Schuldenbremse ein früher
haben das viele fdp-ler Taschenspieler
Tricks genannt also bevor Christian
Lindner Finanzminister wurde jetzt hat
der Rückendeckung auch von seinem
Vorgänger als Finanzminister dem
bazookavums doppelwumms Kanzler und der
sieht auch überhaupt keinen Grund sich
irgendwie zurechtfertigen wegen all
dieser unterschiedlichen Deckel oder wie
Fachleute sagen Schattenhaushalte
das sind keine Schattenhaushalte es ist
alles sehr überschaubar sind nicht im
Schatten denn sie sprechen ja über die
die sind mir offenbar nicht verborgen
geblieben und wir haben sie sogar heute
stolz präsentiert ja da würde man sagen
so eine offensivverteidigung die siehst
du sonst auch nur in der Champions
League also zur Ausgangsfrage was meint
ihr riskiert Christian Lindner mit der
Schuldenbremse die Zukunft der jungen
Generation oder schützt er sie mein FAZ
persönliche Meinung beide Seiten haben
einen Punkt ja es gibt viele gute Gründe
jetzt sehr viel Geld auszugeben wir sind
in der historischen Krise oder besser
gesagt in mehreren und sehr
tiefgreifenden Krisen gleichzeitig aber
das Geld muss trotz allem bzw genau
deswegen möglichst zielgerichtet
ausgegeben werden weil wir müssen all
diese Deckel am Ende bezahlen ja jeder
Strich der drauf kommt muss am Ende
bezahlt werden und deshalb gut überlegt
sein da finde ich hat lindern Punkt wo
er nicht recht hat ist wenn er jetzt so
tut als häufe er zurzeit wenig oder kaum
Schulden für die jüngere Generation an
oder um es in anderen Worten zu sagen
also immer Herr Christian Lindner gerade
macht ganz sicher ganz sicher ist es
nicht so dass Schulden für die kommende
Generation gerade konsequent vermieden
werden wenn auch aus guten Gründen weil
noch mal zur Erinnerung
den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds ein
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr hat den
Energie-
es wird viel Geld ausgegeben und das
ergibt dann ja auch schon eine ganz
hübsche Pointe aus der Perspektive
betrachtet sind die beiden ja in
Wahrheit gar nicht so weit auseinander
und das ist ja vielleicht auch eine sehr
versöhnliche Erkenntnis na da würde ich
doch sagen darauf können wir anstoßen ja
hat mal jemand ein Bier
doppelwumms danke schreibt er auf ja auf
dem Deckel nicht auf meinen auf die
anderen Verteiler so ein bisschen ja
verteile fällt das nicht so auf ja danke
und Prost
läuft